[Musique]
bonjour ravi de vous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 journal
nous sommes le mardi 31 décembre et pour
ce dernier jour de l'année le ministère
de l'intérieur a choisi les yvelines
pour présenter son dispositif général de
sécurisation de la nuit de la saint
sylvestre
laurent nunez et christophe castaner se
sont rendus à la gendarmerie de magny
les hameaux maman varaldo les a suivis à
quelques heures du réveillon du nouvel
an christophe castaner fait le point sur
le dispositif de sécurité accompagné de
laurent nunez secrétaire d'état auprès
du ministre de l'intérieur 140 2100 139
personnes seront mobilisées ce soir la
nuit de la saint sylvestre est l'une des
plus meurtrières sur les routes ce soir
si rien n'est fait et si l'on en suit la
statistique
hélas macabre des accidents de la route
près de 20 personnes vont mourir sur les
routes en france
j'en appelle vraiment à cette réflexion
ce verre de trop vaut-il la peine d'être
but je pense au décès je pense à ces
accidents graves dont on garde des
séquelles des traces tout au long de la
vie et je le dis c'est une demande que
nous avons fait aux forces de
gendarmerie aux policiers aussi d'être
présent sur le bord des routes pour
faire des contrôles sur le département
le chef de la gendarmerie des yvelines
informe qu'un tiers de ses effectifs
sont engagés ce soir soit 227 militaire
renforcée au besoin par 62 autres
militaires mobilisables sous deux heures
en cas d'urgence il ya les comportements
individuels qui mélange la fête avec la
violence est là aussi nous serons
mobilisés sur le terrain nous
connaissons des risques hélas normaux
notamment en matière de risque
terroriste est donc là aussi l'ensemble
de nos services sont mobilisés
nous connaissons une situation qui n'est
pas de tension anormal mais sur laquelle
nous devons faire face
le ministre de l'intérieur et le
secrétaire d'état se sont ensuite rendus
au centre d'incendié et de secours de
bois d'arcy et enfin au commissariat de
plaisir
pour ce réveillon vous êtes nombreux à
préparer un bon dîner la période des
fêtes représente un moment fort pour les
supermarchés qui peuvent augmenter leur
chiffre d'affaires de 20 à 30%
nous nous sommes rendus chez l'un
d'entre eux poursuivre dernier des
achats de l'année du foie gras des
huîtres du saumon ce supermarché à son
rayon dédié aux produits de réveillon
objectif liquider les stocks des fêtes
et en ce 31 décembre on compte sur les
clients de dernière minute ils sont très
nombreux ils sont très nombreux qui vont
chercher une dernière bouteille de
whisky dernière bouteille de champagne
du rhum ou je ne sais quoi ou une motte
de beurre ou des huîtres encore ou voilà
effectivement c'est assez sympa on
trouve de tout selon un observatoire
dédié les français vont dépenser en
moyenne 123 euros pour ce nouvel an on
va manger de rose vif
on va manger des crevettes et on va
manger des escargots et on va manger du
deux fois par rayon alcool on s'assure
que le plein de bouteilles fait c'est
très important c'est une des plus grosse
journée de l'année au niveau de ce rayon
l'a donc effectivement c'est important
faut être plein faut éviter d'avoir des
ruptures pour faire au moins un chiffre
d'affaires égal à celui de l'année
dernière et puis répondre à l'attenté
des clients surtout qu'ils ont ces
périodes de fêtes mais de fait difficile
ont besoin de faire la fête
ce sont pour les invités pour ce soir et
puis qu'on passe une bonne fête
tout est prêt j'étais faire mes courses
mais j'ai oublié le vin de quoi bien
faire la fête pour cette nouvelle
décennie avec modération bien sûr avant
de passer à la galette des rois à 438
millions c'est le nombre d'habitants
dans les yvelines
l'insee a publié les décrets
ministériels officialisant les derniers
chiffres du recensement
le département des yvelines est le
quatrième plus peuplés d'île de france
si vous vous inquiétez de votre
inscription sur les listes électorales
en vue des municipales de 2020 pas de
panique même passé le 31 décembre la
démarche sera toujours possible
vous avez désormais jusqu'au 7 février
pour le faire en vous rendant à la
mairie de votre commune ou sur internet
sur le site officiel de l'administration
française
service public.fr pour rappel les
élections municipales auront lieu les
dimanches 15 et 22 mars
et avant de se quitter direction le parc
national de la haute vallée de chevreuse
qui développe en ce moment sa stratégie
solaire au travers d'actions collectives
sur les énergies renouvelables avec
notamment la mise en place de centrales
solaires collective gérée par des
coopérations de citoyens gwenaëlle
sentiments le parc naturel régional de
la haute vallée de chevreuse souhaite
développer son territoire solaire
notamment au travers des centrales
solaires collective
on distingue aujourd'hui deux types de
projets les projets participatifs et les
projets citoyens avec la création de
coopération l'idée c'est de rassembler
un certain nombre de bénévoles qui vont
s'associer se réunir travailler ensemble
pour voir comment et sur quelle toiture
mettre des panneaux photovoltaïques avec
un financement un montage juridique
entre des citoyens bénévoles comme par
exemple sur une école sur une salle
municipale sur sur une grange est
financé par les citoyens donc
aujourd'hui sur le parc nous avons un
collectif d'une quinzaine de personnes
qui existe qui fonctionne qui
travaillent qui a formé des groupes de
travail qui travaille notamment avec la
mairie de manier les un mot sur laquelle
un certain nombre de voitures ont été
identifiés en fait on allait voir les de
faisabilité savoir si et c'est adéquat
c'est plein de facteurs qui font que
les toits sont exploitables pas pour
mettre les photos des panneaux donc ça
va deux ans de l'orientation jusqu'à
l'inclinaison d'attention et juger la
solidité des gens pensent
et là on a vu vraiment un toit qui était
vraiment très intéressant
alors c'était un centre de loisirs à 100
de loisirs en plus c'est un gros aspect
pédagogique parce que a du coup il y
aura des enfants
il faut donc maintenant engagé des
procédures pour mettre en place le
projet particuliers collectivités et
entreprises
les motivations sont nombreuses pour
rejoindre ce collectif
aujourd'hui mon amour ou qui se
découpent et on un perte de lien entre
les gens aiment beaucoup le projet c'est
l'occasion de mettre du lien à l'échelle
locale est bon ça c'est quelque chose de
très fort il faut tous passer du temps
pour que les choses changent rapidement
et donc du coup il ya un petit peu quand
même de l'urgence face à tout ça je
pense qu'aujourd'hui dans ce monde si on
veut pouvoir vraiment moi c'est de
manière solide il faut noter des
collectifs ça va nous permettre de
monter des projets qui seront
économiquement viable bah pour moi c'est
un projet qui est essentiel pour
l'avenir parce que l'énergie et
l'environnement nombre sont des
questions cruciales
je les fais miennes la devise qui est
penser globalement et agir localement
que je voudrais aussi mon frère mes
petits-enfants que j'ai fait quelque
chose pour la planète tant projet je
veux je veux apporter quelque chose je
veux être là pour aider à 7
cette transmission de savoirs c'est la
nouvelle énergie
c'est ce qu'il faut pour le futur je
veux pas transmettre des déchets le côté
citoyen de la chose
la deuxième motivation c'est
l'énergie tout ce qui peut contribuer à
diminuer ce réchauffement
la sobriété énergétique mais aussi des
énergies renouvelables ce appareil
vraiment important plus tôt mme investir
dans un projet concret qui qui fasse
vraiment avancer les choses mais de
façon concrète pour l'art pour moi c'est
une façon de mutualiser
les la production d'énergie au lieu de
le faire chacun dans son coin et nertiti
l'alex qui la laisse l'ouest essonne le
parc naturel et énergie partagée
accompagne le groupe dans ce projet de
centrale solaire dans le parc naturel
régional de la haute vallée de chevreuse
vous êtes intéressés pour rejoindre le
projet rendez vous sur le site du parc
pour connaître toutes les actualités et
informations
c'est la fin de cette édition le 7-8
journal continue de vous accompagner en
2020 et revient dès le 2 janvier en
attendant toute l'équipe vous souhaite
un bon réveillon
[Musique]